How close should I have the RIFE ball to my body during sleeping? Should I be concerned about EMF exposure?
There's no EMFs that are coming out of the ball, so you don't need to worry about that. I made a video
on EMFs coming from your computer. I used the EMF meter to measure EMFs coming from your RIFE computer,
and that was just about zero. The only EMFs that I did have coming from the computer is when I
connected it to the internet. When you have your computer on airplane mode like you're supposed to,
you really shouldn't be getting any EMFs. When you hit run on your computer and then you close
it so it goes to sleep, it's not producing any EMFs. There isn't any EMF issues. How close should
you have the RIFE ball to your body while you're sleeping is as close as you possibly can? You should
stungle with it if possible. If all I can't do that, it just drives me crazy. Then leave it six inches
away. I roll over and I roll on it. Can I leave it 12 inches away? Yeah, you can, but every 12 inches
that you move away from the object, you're decreasing the benefit of the frequency. So yeah, if you're
doing much better and you're in full remission, you can keep it 12 inches away. That's just fine.
But like I've always recommended it and I know some physicists might get out and say,
no, you're going to still get just as much treatment if your 24 inches away than you are,
then if it's right next to you, maybe. But for me, I just think the closer it is to your
to the source of the injury, I think the better it's going to be.